If you haven't seen Deadpool, but you like
what you see from Deadpool 2's amazing marketing
campaign, then you should probably go rent
Deadpool.
It's pretty hilarious, but it's not for kids.
Even though the sequel is only the second
movie in the series, it's a part of the long-running,
extra-confusing X-Men franchise.
Making matters even crazier, Deadpool 2 is
bringing in a ton of extra heroes from the
comics.
If you're planning to see the Merc with a
Mouth in action, but just don't have the time
for Deadpool, or maybe you just want to know
who all these new people are, here's everything
you need to know before seeing Deadpool 2.
Mr. Pool
Deadpool is Wade Wilson, a mercenary with
a military black ops past.
The first job we see him work is scaring a
nerdy pizza delivery guy out of stalking the
object of his obsession.
He uses the money he gets from the gig for
a night of fun with his soon to be main squeeze,
Vanessa.
Wilson and Vanessa spend a wild year together
until Wilson learns he's dying from cancer.
With no other options available, Wilson agrees
to undergo an experimental treatment that
he's told will turn him into a superhero.
He doesn't learn until later that the program's
patients are actually super-powered slaves
sold off to the highest bidder.
The experiments give Wilson the ability to
heal from just about any wound, but they also
make his skin look like Freddy Krueger's.
On his off time, Wilson frequents a bar called
"Sister Margaret's" that's patronized mainly
by mercenaries.
The bar's owner, Weasel, hosts a Dead Pool
in which the rowdy customers can bet on who
among them will die next, which inspires Wilson's
code name.
Deadpool's staple move is breaking the fourth
wall.
He knows he's a fictional character, and he
revels in it.
His movie takes plenty of potshots at other
superhero movies, particularly the X-Men series.
The character also pokes fun at Reynolds himself,
through jokes about his performances in Green
Lantern and X-Men Origins: Wolverine.
The cable guy
There was a time in the '90s when it seemed
like just about every new X-Men character
was from some kind of dystopian alternate
future.
Cable is one of these time-crossed refugees.
Played by Josh Brolin, Cable is Nathan Summers,
the child of Cyclops and a clone of Jean Grey
who's sent into the future and returns, initially
to take over command of the X-Men's junior
team, the New Mutants.
Cable's cybernetic enhancements are due to
a lethal techno-organic virus slowly turning
his body into a machine.
Luckily, he's also a mutant with telepathic
and telekinetic powers, which he uses to keep
the virus at bay.
That's the Cable of the comics, but we don't
know how different the Cable of Deadpool 2
will be, just that he'll be from the future,
he's a cyborg, and he's a formidable warrior.
We also know that Cable has come to the present
to with his sights on a teenager named Russell
for reasons unknown.
Speaking of whom...
The new kid
The kid that Cable's hunting in the trailers
remains shrouded in mystery.
We know his name is Russell, and that he seems
to have pyrokinetic powers, giving us a solid
idea of his comic inspiration.
Russell is likely inspired by Rusty Collins,
a.k.a. Firefist.
First appearing in the pages of X-Factor,
he's able to manipulate fire, much like Pyro
from X-Men 2.
What we still don't know is what Cable wants
with him.
Does Russell somehow cause the dark future
that Cable's from?
Or is this solely a mission of personal vengeance?
Either way, Deadpool takes up the cause of
defending the kid, assembling a new team to
take Cable out.
The luckiest lady
Neena Thurman, a.k.a. Domino, is the end result
of a government breeding project designed
to produce the perfect killer.
Domino is surrounded at all times by a "probability
field" that affects her and her enemies.
Try to shoot at Domino, and there's a good
chance your gun will jam, or even explode
in your face.
If Domino leaps from the top of a tall building
with no plan of survival, something is likely
to come along and cushion or stop her fall.
Much like Deadpool, Domino's relationships
with Marvel's other mutants tend to be somewhat
tenuous.
Unlike the X-Men, she's no moral crusader,
but she'll often work alongside them if there's
an opportunity for fun, profit, or both.
She first appeared in the pages of the X-Men
comic X-Force, making her a natural fit for
the version of the team assembling in Deadpool
2.
Pure bedlam
Introduced during 1995's alternate universe
Age of Apocalypse event, Bedlam was originally
the collective name of two brothers: Jesse
and Christopher Aaronson.
After that story wrapped up, Jesse Aaronson
was re-introduced in the pages of X-Force.
Bedlam produces an electromagnetic field that
allows him to disrupt different forms of energy,
creating havoc in both people and machines.
He's also a martial arts expert.
Again, there's no way to know until opening
day how faithful Terry Crews' portrayal will
be to the comics; only that, like his comic
book counterpart, Bedlam will be joining the
ranks of X-Force.
Who is Shatterstar?
If you think Cable's origin story is convoluted,
wait till you meet Shatterstar.
In the comics, Shatterstar is from a place
called Mojoworld, a planet that exists a century
in the future and is ruled by the tyrannical
villain Mojo.
Mojoworld is obsessed with entertainment,
and Shatterstar was a slave who was genetically
engineered to be a gladiator.
He has enhanced strength and agility, heals
faster than most, is a master at many different
fighting styles, can channel shockwaves through
weaponry, and can even open portals allowing
people to instantly teleport to wherever they'd
like.
As far as his origin in Deadpool 2 is concerned,
it's likely it will have nothing to do with
Mojoworld.
But considering how much Deadpool made fun
of comic book movie tropes, who knows?
We could have a scene with Cable, Bedlam,
and Shatterstar all comparing dystopian futures,
debating whose is worse.
Peter and Hydra Bob
Who is Peter?
Well, the short answer is that we don't know.
There's some speculation that he's Deadpool
2's answer to longtime Deadpool comics character
Hydra Bob.
Hydra Bob is, on the surface, a kind of useless
sidekick to Deadpool.
He's cowardly, bad at fighting, and has absolutely
no special skills.
He's a member of Hydra who will often cite
Hydra training maxims, such as "if I can't
see them they can't see me" and "hiding behind
each other."
He generally responds to every situation by
running away.
The character actually had an unofficial cameo
in Deadpool.
He's never referred to as "Hydra Bob" because
20th Century Fox didn't have the rights to
that character, but Deadpool calls him Bob
and they briefly talk about working together
in Jacksonville.
He's among the only ones of Ajax's henchmen
that Deadpool knocks unconscious and doesn't
kill.
It's possible that Fox wanted a Hydra Bob
for Deadpool 2, and simply created their own
schlub with a different name because they
didn't have the rights.
Not that Marvel universe
Though Deadpool is a Marvel Comics character,
he doesn't live anywhere near the mostly family-friendly,
Disney-owned Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Though Deadpool is not technically a mutant,
he's one of the many Marvel characters owned
by 20th Century Fox as part of the movie rights
to the X-Men's roster of heroes and villains.
So Deadpool doesn't have to worry about going
up against Thanos anytime soon.
Disney is currently in the process of buying
and merging with Fox, meaning that actual
crossovers will likely be possible in the
future.
But until then, Deadpool is most definitely
banned from Disney World.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!